hey hey hey hello everybody my name is
Marc barn welcome back to 3 scary games
this one is called the filth breed this
is gonna be scary hopefully [ __ ] would
you like to read the tutorial yes I
guess click to advance the slideshow
narration use the arrow keys to move in
the mouse to look around once you find a
firearm scroll up on the mouse wheel to
draw your gun and click to shoot you
can't interact with objects and your
surroundings if you're ready to open
fire lower your guard and holster your
weapon by scrolling down click on
objects in to interact with them
depending on the prompts shown at the
bottom of the screen and it was sparse
and there's no health recovery so don't
go in guns a-blazing alright ok yeah
homeless shelters all over the state
have reported the disappearance of
several people in the past few months
investigators are pointing to michigan
truck driver louis burton as a prime
suspect having a well-documented track
record of smuggling cocaine across the
border he too is nowhere to be found his
former partner has confirmed Burton's
involvement in the case but remains
adamant that he's not absconded
according to his testimony Burton's then
recruited by a local cult and held
captive in an unknown location all these
claims have yet to be verified a
transport truck matching that of his
suspect has been located next to a
warehouse in the outskirts of Detroit
higher-ups remain skeptical but you've
been tasked to search the area for any
evidence pertaining to the case alright
no great love it let me I'm out you turn
back straightaway and tell your superior
you quick return and Shore for raises
some eyebrows in the office but nobody
was buying that cult nonsense anyway you
feel like an absolute coward and quit
the foolish the trail goes cold
[Laughter]
[ __ ] okay well let's ride again show all
right okay all right let's just keep
gonna skip on that little diddly all
right here we are backing it again I
always love anything like that that's
always fun the way it was talking it
reminded me a lot of cry of fear you
know like the way it was talking about
the inventory management the way it was
talking about the guns like it seems
interesting except no super juice bulb
you were right Sally we should never
have trusted these crazy they keep us
all down here in the dark trap like
cattle we're just animals to them some
of us are even starting to act the part
this is Lucas guy walks around on all
fours and bites you when you're sleeping
I miss you Sally I miss the gang back
home I miss Brightmoor I hear them
chanting again it's time time for why I
scream I took the gun right out of his
pocket in the Indian didn't even flinch
if only I had the balls to do it before
it's too late for me now whoever's
reading this I pray you can make better
use of it just don't bother aiming for
the head
I've seen those freaks last well over a
week without it oh you found an old
Glock scroll up to equip it and click -
oh God alright do I have unlimited ammo
no I'm guessing no very much like cry
fear probably okay great can I leave now
can I go back home oh this is not the
way I owe it is where maybe I could
maybe I could Oh can't leave now
alright wait maybe I could I don't want
to leave now I just get the ultimate
what sending or maybe the smart choice
ending also if I'm a police officer why
don't have a gun myself you know even
the health bar looks and the gun ammo
icon looks a lot like cry fear
I'm wondering if they drew inspiration
from that because if they did and even
the enemy kind of looked like cry fear
if they did I'm totally down with that
because I haven't played a game like cry
fear in so long
that's like Resident Evil animations are
cool I bet if I reload this I'm gonna
lose that ammo so I'm not gonna reload
until I absolutely have to bang I'm
aiming for the head even though they
told me not to probably doesn't make a
big difference but I'm doing it not sure
what that's about but it's probably okay
every time I wake up there are roaches
in my mouth are they getting in are they
coming out that's what as you put that
in my brain clever little buggers
pulling out my teeth laying eggs under
my tongue
I can't chew or spit yeah every time I
wake up there are roaches in my mouth
are they getting in okay coming out I
can't take it yeah thanks for giving me
a new phobia appreciate that
prease you big prease big three shun the
phobia
all right that's probably fine what time
is it what day is it
it all just blends together after a
while I can't even tell dreams from
reality anymore no matter if I open or
close my eyes it's only this pitch black
shroud around me what's worse is the
things I do here I wish I didn't this
calling hands and feet all over the
ceiling and they can't all be mine how
are your hands and feet on the ceiling
all right oh I can't it's okay I didn't
want to go there I didn't want to go in
there at all anyway actually oh well
what is it that could get bad oh oh oh
hey looking at here excuse you and
excuse me holy [ __ ] why who did that
anyway that's awful everything about
that horrible this cult no good I you
know I I'm normally very accepting of
cults this cult no I think something bad
about it okay back into it man this is
good this is good what they got going on
here is really good it just shows like
you can have something that's like
simpler in terms of graphics simpler in
terms of animation it can still be
really scary there's a reason why games
made in the past 10 years are still
really scary so where did that guy come
from I don't think I can follow oh okay
oh good it's like a classroom learning
they're a little fun cult oh its day I
did not think it was day oh that's a
maze okay all right
oh this seems fun thus Spoke the
slumbering prophet gore Goren wait sorry
hang on thus Spoke the slumbering
prophet
auto-tuned it took a sick God to imagine
a world this filthy it took a phial God
to shape the world is cruel it makes you
borrow this filthy to shelter us all in
its putrid bosom engine that's not what
I was hoping for it for this we are but
we are what the shadows of a madman's
dancing fire man is not doomed but
destined to ruin man is not to courage
but to fester the world which innards
reveal the path bring forth the lights
mother the lice mother
no thanks I'm okay big big pass on that
one I'm okay without the lice mother you
know what I'm saying
just don't need that in my life bring me
the life mother if you know what I'm
talking about
right this looks great all going good
all going good looking
yeah let's go in here now
oh it's wet Oh God roaches oh no what is
this uh uh nobody this game was called
filth breed oh so gross
oh it's so splooshing I don't trust a
goddamn thing in this place
Oh trust a gosh darn thing
who burped who just burped why are you
burping who's that me did I burp by
burping whoa hey hey whoa hey whoa No
you're gonna do that to me I'm gonna do
that to you that's what you oh I came
full circle oh it's the same oh yeah
it's Wow I came full circle can I leave
now I would love to leave leaving would
be the best but I don't know if I'm
definitely done so you know could go at
any time I guess but it for some reason
I'm real persistent oh and I can't even
go this way oh well I guess I'll go you
block the iron bull there in door and
take him home to bask in the Sun out of
the reach of those creatures back at the
station you debrief your superior on
everything you found you don't even
bother trying not to sound crazy after a
moment of awkward silence he finally
congratulate cyou for the good work he
then suggest you take a couple day break
you go home and try your best to get
some sleep come morning you wake up to
the news of a fire at the warehouse
the place went up in flames well before
a team could be dispatched to check on
your findings it's all gone 12 bodies
have been recovered so far the police
are hesitant to identify them as human
they're hardened hollow like man shaped
chitin shells
hahahahahaha wait so what are the
endings to this game oh hang on I gotta
go back in I gotta go back in this is
this one was so gross but it was so well
made okay number one what happens if you
get the gun and leave like right a like
if you get the gun shoot the guy leave
you know kind of like go for that cuz
there's gotta be something that I missed
you know what I mean cuz I didn't do
anything I didn't solve anything okay
you're gonna nah just try warning shot
okay good alright then I just leave what
happens about err what can I go this way
I can't right
no like definitely can what happens if I
save enough bullets to shoot like all
the bugs yeah okay you make the sensible
decision to turn back whatever's going
on there it's not normal you're not
prepared for this kind of situation the
guys of the station have a field day
with your report you're not the first
rookie to lose their temper under
pressure the veterans will handle this
one three officers under the warehouse
won't leave one of them makes it back
right leg maimed and infested with
larvae she's in a state of shock and can
barely muster the words to explain what
happened in there she gassed something
about feeding mom before collapsing you
know it's not your fault but you feel
responsible you granted a two-week break
from the force and never returned the
case didn't make the news you bought on
with your life but years later you still
have dreams about it tactical retreat
wow this game went full-on sicko mode
okay there's got to be something else
that I can do there's got to be
something else
it's got to be like a secret or
something you know what I mean because
there's got to be something because
there's like it's gotta be something
right maybe there's not but I really
hope there is I really hope there is
like what if I actually shoot the bugs
what if I shoot the larvae yeah I need
to save my bullets
oh you're good speed run baby
oh [ __ ] no no no no whoa you're a toughy
yeah what is with the bang boom 'n yeah
what's the big boom all about what are
you about I don't know maybe it's just
meant to look scary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay got it and then perfect now I've
got one full clip ready for whatever
dastardly demons are there and also what
is that can I shoot that know if I want
to waste my ammo on that thing shoot you
nope nope how about this you oh oh
you can shoot um oh did I waste my
bullets I bet there are exactly the
number of roaches that you can shoot
wait maybe not maybe okay maybe not
there's there's a lot of roaches in here
there's a little okay there's a lot of
roaches maybe I shoulda shot one of the
eggs yeah I pushed you shut the eggs I
don't even have an oh I don't have
enough to survive this don't no no
please please
welp okay there are only three endings I
think there are only three endings okay
so that's it that's it that's it for
that one but but but very cool very well
done very well done
I loved this very scary very scary very
gross very good I like it that's really
cool okay so moving on to the next game
this one is called the pizza Lord I
don't know why it's called the pizza
lord and I don't know why there's a
pentagram up here above the pizza oven
and I feel like asking questions this
early into a game is only a bad sign but
I'm gonna go for it you are a chef who
tries to make a living in a big city you
move there to fulfill your dream to run
your own restaurant so far you have
found nothing but failure on your
journey despite all the warnings from
your friends you followed your heart and
created a themed restaurant with a
satanic theme great the theme is good
enough but as you started working you
learned that you are actually very poor
at making pizzas ah that's problem one
night when you were cleaning out the
kitchen you notice that someone is
sitting in one of the chairs in the
dining area you were surprised since you
usually notice when people come in
because no one ever does you can't quite
see them in the dim light but you can
see two white eyes gleaming in the
darkness
play a game with our Lord sacrifice for
things and he will come to your aid he
points at the pizza oven and you look at
it when you turn back to ask him
questions he is already gone click to
start yeah yeah let's sacrifice some
people to the pizza devil let's do it
only good can come from that
bring it Wow hello-o I demand a cold
sacrifice what oh ok a cold nice beer is
that what you want
shoes that's pretty cold this is a flask
with holy water
oh in the fridge of course there's
nothing in the fridge utensils glass
harmonica stuff animal love your pizza
Necronomicon leather whip pack of smokes
cold waters cold try that yeah don't
throw that stuff at me I'm sorry
it was cold though maybe I can pick up
the whole refrigerator or anything in
there can I open this no utensils are
cold metal is cold I have enough
silverware in hell oh alright sure how
about my pizza it's so cold it's just
been sitting out have some of my pizza
eh it's my pizza oh yes cold and
tasteless hey those are my feelings you
don't want to hurt him of my feelings of
demand a hot sacrifice oh these shoes so
hot
Peck smokes very hot very hot right so
hot nope alright well [ __ ]
Sade what do you want what do you want
for me what do you want
alright pizza you got it yeah yeah
called intesa yeah yeah yeah alright hot
you got it baby you got it
um holy water it burns so that's hot oh
god damn it okay fine
these shoes they are hot
huh you don't have any style well shut
up goat really the goat the goat was hot
to you god damn it okay unusually
disgusting sorry about my pizza okay you
talking about my pizza again aren't you
talking about my pizza worst pizza in
all 660 all right well that hurts my
feelings that's of my feelings demand a
sharp sacrifice you you make me I feel
you make me cry you make me feel like
I'm not good enough utensils this is
what you wanted oops
alright well fine oh yeah cold yeah okay
but nice oh my pizza yeah yeah it's uh
my grandma's recipe yeah yeah cold and
tasteless yeah just like your face okay
here's a goat for hotness don't know why
this is hot to you well the would have
caught fire sooner or later okay yeah
that's any right disgusting sacrifice
okay my pizza alright here we go
let's go with this one here yeah there
we go yep still hurts still hurts it
still hurts
alright a sharp sacrifice rather nothing
sharper than the crack of the whip or
the crack of my wit if you know what I'm
talking about oh yeah okay nope on that
one big no pie right you okay how's
about you alright harmonica oh it's uh
plays sharp notes
haizao that news gets out sharp notes
that's right a sharp hat I know how it
do yeah my grandma taught me about that
oh [ __ ] suddenly the mystic is back he
produces a notebook out of thin air he
carefully inspects it our Lord is
satisfied you feel your legs weakened as
objects around you blur and you pass out
hours later you wake up on the floor
it's morning you can hear people outside
as you peekaboo window you're shocked
that the ruckus comes from a line of
people waiting to come to your
restaurant you feel like you have a
hundred years of combined pizza making
powers you start preparing the kitchen
yeah you feel like something's missing
inside the the end
okay ten out of ten 11 out of 20 so good
was good it's good it's good it's good
it's good game good game it for a game
jam so I can't [ __ ] on it so kids good
it's good good game good game good game
alright so this one's called the
concrete crown
you hear that concrete crown oh oh this
looks fun my hand looks very much like
salad fingers hands what the machines
vomit shadows remember to turn on your
lights oh oh what oh oh I know you said
descend but I'm gonna a send it cuz I
don't want to be here I don't think I
want to know what's happening I'm
ascending I'm ascending wait is this
gonna be infinite I bet it's infinite
isn't it Oh No alright yeah it looks
pretty infinite alright descending it is
here we go baby here we go it's SCP the
staircase thing Oh eight seven B or
whatever it was
alright great wonderful I don't think
it's I don't think it's actually an SCP
i7b
game but that being said that doesn't
mean that it can't take a little bit of
creativity from it and something about
the the darkness vomiting shadows or
something like that
I don't know I don't know man oh well a
whole lot of nothing so far probably
because I went up first
I was probably supposed to hit some
stuff one going down sooner but you know
how it be oh hi hello
oh that looks like a fun door oh that
door looks fun
Wow hey how you doing in here a place
for ghosts to wonder to realize they are
dead oh my god okay goodbye
thank you well good advice you have
really helps me in my time of need
oh good another door great wonderful
hello oh so cat no it's shadows
that's barbed wire well this isn't fun
can I touch that apparently not
I thought those are cat sticking its
head out but apparently those are
vomiting shadows okay good good to know
Oh hopes condemned to gnaw and fester
still born in your head okay cool great
that's a weird machine but okay good
great
alright this is real fun it's great just
wonderful out of this place of happiness
yeah a whole lot of nothing happening oh
god another door I can't wait for
another freak show of horror coming at
my way oh good more of those oh they're
vomiting shadows great I get to listen
to more words
I can't wait oh god bless our skulls
with a concrete crowns and bind our
minds with three a thread ah thanks
thank you thank you for that
okay good lots of machines vomiting
shadows don't know why though never got
a solid answer a why I hear something no
you're not gonna keep going on that one
you're just gonna pretend low good
didn't have any room left in in there
for him oh my god oh my god okay yeah
filled to the brim knows no lie alright
well great this is great this is
wonderful I bet there would have been
something if I would gone up
I don't think this is procedurally
generated I think this is all scripted
or all pre-built because if it was
procedurally generated that'd be one
thing but it seems like he's all
pre-built that means there probably was
a top because it couldn't have gone
forever whereas some of the SCP o8 7b
games were procedurally generated heck
that game came before us to be
containment breach hello why hello are
you chasing me what's happening am I
getting closer to something or is it
coming down the stairs I don't know if I
should be panicked about this or
hesitant it really sounds like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay well we're at the bottom
now I guess Oh God
okay all right here we go Oh God
throw your flesh into the pit the
Pistons must be fandant good advice man
good advice all right into the pit I go
then some you see all right cool well
nevermind that all right let's put her I
don't know how Oh
also what the hell oh jeez okay well
that's that's funky all right well I
don't think I can fit in this hole here
I go oh here oh great Oh beautiful oh so
intricate okay
Oh
whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh
okay uh but that's a sight for sore eyes
Bow Wow Wow
well this is my stop I got it I got it
yeah he's gonna tug out there we go see
ya what happened I have no idea oh good
hey what's up hey how you doing eh yes
Oh nope we're done okay well I guess
that's all there is for that game so
hope you guys learned something that was
a really enlightening experience I feel
good about myself I hope you feel good
about yourself and so that was three
scary games thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see more
scary games you can check out the scary
games playlist a whole bunch of other
games that I played in the past all very
scary link is in the description and if
you've got other scary games do you want
me to play put them in the comments
thanks again and as always I will see
you
[Music]